maybe you want to pop off your own
fourth of july fireworks well
the sale of legal fireworks starts today
those are the ones that have been tested
approved by our fire departments they're
called
safe and sane hector mejia live at a
local fireworks stand with some
important information if you're planning
to get some
hector most of these are for non-profits
organizations as well aren't they
that's true and they work to raise a lot
of funds the one right behind me for
example working to raise funds for the
local homeless community and you can
only pop the legal fireworks this week
now through july 4th
and this is a tnt fireworks stand and
they tell us do not be surprised if you
run into a limited selection this year
at stands
and that's because there's a shortage
affecting the entire industry
the only legal fireworks in clark county
as nate just mentioned are labeled safe
and sane those are the ones that stay
close to the ground and you can get them
at fireworks stands in your neighborhood
starting today
if you're caught with anything illegal
that's anything that shoots up into the
air you could get a fine of 250 to a
thousand dollars
and you also risk some fire damage
possibly with the amount of dry
vegetation around the valley safety
experts are asking you
please be careful when you choose to be
a consumer fireworks you got to do that
responsibly
so we want to make sure everybody
remembers to follow the safety tips that
are out there be responsible
pick the right kind of site for your
fireworks show
flat surface concrete or paved watch out
for any type of flammables
also have a water source nearby to put
out any sparks and make sure the
fireworks are cold
before throwing them away and if you
need to report any illegal fireworks
don't call 9-1-1 authorities say to use
ispy fireworks.com just like last year
remember police will not respond right
away if you report an illegal
firework on that website they just take
all of that information
and use that information to identify
trouble spots reporting live this
morning hector mejia
8 news now